welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the thief that stole the hearts of
millions and this video we're breaking
down lupone
the fantastic french series has just
dropped on netflix with five phenomenal
episodes
in this video we're gonna be going over
the plot and it's enigmatic
ending obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out yet then i highly
recommend that you check out now
if you enjoy this video then please
click the thumbs up button and make sure
you subscribe to the channel to be
constantly kept in the loop
lupin terrible anyway without the way
thank you
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so lupan is based loosely on the
gentleman thief of the same name
who's appeared in countless crime capers
or more created in 1905 by
writer maurice leblanc he became famous
throughout the century
due to his thrilling adventures and
storylines the series itself feels very
much like a cross between sherlock and
hustle
two british tv shows that show the
ingenuity of their character with
jaw-dropping reveals that come at the
end of an episode
the netflix series is no different and
we follow a character known as hassan
whose father was framed when he was
younger
accused of stealing the necklace of
marry antoinette from the family he was
working for
assan's dad hanged himself and since
then the orphan is set out to uncover
the truth
now throughout the series we learned
that it was actually the owner of the
necklace
a man named hubert pellegrini who was
behind its disappearance
hubert is a rich and ruthless man who
was on the verge of bankruptcy and thus
he framed asan's father in order to
claim the insurance money
with help from a detective and his own
wife anne they coaxed him into
confessing over the crime
and thus were able to get away with it
yes son of a [ __ ]
now though they got off with it
scot-free the insurance money didn't
cover all of the bills
and thus pellegrini had to make a deal
with a bunch of terrorists in order to
get money
this was actually caught on tape by a
journalist named fabian
and assam managed to get a hold of it at
one point in the series
this made it seem like he would finally
have the bad guy banged to right
but pellegrini unfortunately had other
plans
assange went to a local news network to
expose the villain and his past
but at the last minute pellegrini had it
swapped out with a doctor tape
which made him look completely innocent
this dude anyway pellegrini sent
a henchman to kill fabian and after
coming face to face with him
assange realized that he needed to get
out of dodge hassan ended up fleeing
with his wife and son
though it wasn't too long before they
were tracked down
now we can confirm that though assan and
claire are separated
they're technically still married which
answers one of the big questions that
hangs
over the season it turns out she was
well aware of what he was up to
and wasn't sure over whether the pair
really had a future together
you do have let's say extracurricular
activities
claire very much believes from time to
time that hassan is her soulmate
and that they're connected however she
also has doubts over their relationship
especially because he doesn't mind
robbing an old lady of her family jewels
it's revealed that he was also having an
affair with juliet pellegrini
which would definitely make things very
very awkward at christmas either way
though
they are indeed very much still
interested in one another which you can
tell from their interactions
as they take a train trip together we
learn that the pair were very happy that
they were having a child together
and their son raul was actually born on
december 11th
which just so happens to also be maurice
leblanc's birthday
a bit of a side tangent then just
talking about the relationships but
i know people had questions over it so i
just sort of clear it up now
claire does still deserve some happiness
and i think that this is why his son
isn't objecting to her dating mark who
just so happens to text her on the train
after the three take a family photo
together asan realizes that hubert's
henchman has been following them
and thus for the finale he enacts a plan
to take him out the picture
over this season asan had been slowly
implicating an alter ego
named paul cenin in his crimes by posing
as the character for several of the big
events
after using that name and stealing the
necklace at the louvre the police had
been on the lookout for him
and he tipped them off to his
whereabouts after placing a diamond from
the necklace inside the henchman's
pocket
it looked like it was all finally over
however we did discover that the
henchman gave an alibi for the night
that the necklace was stolen
and therefore he was let free by police
it's also possible that demand had a
hand in this but
we don't offer definite just just
speculating there anyway
claire well aware that something was up
with the man on the train
started to ask questions about what was
really going on and assange said that it
all tied back to his father
claire is sick of being trapped in his
vicious cycle seemed frustrated over
going through the rigmarole again
and assange asked for one more chance
however before he got an answer
claire realized that raul had gone
missing and the character
was absolutely nowhere at all on the
beach judo raul wearing a lupine costume
and all that were present at the beach
he disappeared without a trace
and to make matters worse a policeman
who was obsessed with lupine as much as
the sand was
arrived after tracking him down that's
how the season ended but
what's going on and how will he get out
of it
well with part two already being teased
at the end of the show
there are a lot of things that we can
take from this the second lot of
episodes has already been filmed
and i can imagine that netflix are gonna
do what they've done with similar shows
such as snowpiercer
which two had all their work done before
the release date hit
typically they tend to wait until enough
enthusiasm is built up around a show and
i can actually see a lot of people being
interested in what's to come
as this is a really good first entry now
the first question you probably have is
what happened to raul the henchman
clearly has his son
and knows that he will likely hand
himself over in order to save his family
on the train the pair actually
interacted and even discussed lupine
so it's not too much of a stretch to
imagine that he could lure him out with
something during the celebrations
now what exactly is going to happen with
the policeman well
we know that he's pretty much gone rogue
at this point and therefore i can
actually see the pair teaming up instead
of a sand being arrested or worse
both are lupine superfans and the san
will probably find common ground with
him
over the shed love of the character
lupan is very much seen as a sort of
robin hood-like figure that only does
bad things in the name of good
and i think that this common interest
will help assange get out of the
predicament
at the heart of this show is taking down
pellegrini
and i think that once asan explains
exactly what's going on that the
attention will switch to huber instead
of him
allowing the pair to team up rather than
being enemies
now hassan of course wants to make it so
that his father is no longer seen as a
guilty man
and i actually have a fan theory that he
may still be alive and hiding out
somewhere not 100 on this yeah but we're
here now so we might as well discuss it
because hey
it's locked down in the uk and there's
nothing else to do anyway
if you cast your mind back to the prison
episode in the season
you'll remember that assange escaped by
faking a hanging that allowed him to get
out of jail
this was eerily similar to the death of
his father i think that it could be
hinting to us that his dad actually
managed to get out of the prison
in a similar way again it's unlikely but
i i just thought i'd throw that in there
as it's a possible twist for part do
the framing was quite similar i think it
was shown to the audience to hint to us
that there are ways to bring all pops
back
if needs be he also owes a son about 30
years of birthday presents
so enjoy explaining where you've been
all this time yeah bum i'm sorry he was
a nice guy anyway
i had a lot of fun with this season and
this short but sweet series
if it felt like a cool way to start the
air i knew omar
sai is bishop from x-men days of future
past and to see him really in a much
more fleshed out role
it really allowed him to shine if you're
a fan of shows like hustle and sherlock
then you'll find a lot to like here you
just probably want to watch it with the
subs instead of dubs
as as they are a bit off from time to
time anyway i felt like the first
episode was really good
and then the series sort of declined
more and more as it went on with the
latter episodes being slightly less
slick than the opening ones
decline sounds like a bit of a harsh
word but you know what i mean
the louvre heist was hard to top the
prison one was great
and then it kind of got less and less
the longer it went on
it was fun though wasn't it and before
you start yeah i am excited for part two
and if i had to score this i'd give it
an eight out of ten
you son of a [ __ ] now i'd obviously
love to hear your thoughts on the series
and don't forget that on the 30th of
january we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit
and lord of the rings 4k box set to your
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the season the links to our
socials are in the description
and you can also support the channel by
clicking the join button and as a thank
you you get videos like this early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
pieces of a woman which will be linked
on screen right now
yeah it's depressing but it's a film
that definitely deserves some attention
especially over the ending which which
is quite ambiguous anyway that's that's
linked on screen right now
and thanks for sitting through the video
with me i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace